Kim Kardashian claps back at her
daughter Chicago on Instagram posting an
epic White House throwback I don't know
what's gonna top that okay let's rewind
and get you up to speed last month Kim
shared the sweet messages that her four
kiddos she shares with her ex Kanye West
filmed for her on Mother's Day
every day
[Applause]
sweet right I'm very happy well she also
shared this worksheet where shy filled
in the blanks when asked about the best
meal her mom cooks Shy's response mom
doesn't cook she has a chef having kids
is just there's no way to describe it
but it's a lot yeah Kim posted a crying
laughing emoji alongside that answer and
on Monday she called back to that subtle
shade from her five-year-old when she
shared these throwback kitchen snaps
from a past visit to the White House
that's Kim slicing a tomato and we gotta
say she has better knife skills than her
little sister Kendall Jenner I'm not a
good cutter so don't zoom in on me
I'm not professional whatsoever hey Chef
do you want to cut this up for her I'll
do it Mom but back to Kim yes she shared
this pic of her final product a Sammy
that her daughter North seemingly loved
the caption that one time in the white
house kitchen when I actually cooked a
grilled cheese way before Shy's time and
that's what we call a mic drop I swear
I'm really good and while Kim may or may
not be a whiz in the kitchen one thing
we do know she's a great mom I'd say
parenting is the thing that has taught
me the most about myself
it has been the most challenging thing
the reality star recently opened up
about co-parenting nine-year-old North
seven-year-old Saint five-year-old
Chicago and four-year-old Psalm with
Kanye following their divorce last
November after six years of marriage I
always think everything in life comes
our way to really teach us something and
it's a really hard task when you have
four kids and you know they all want to
be put to bed at the same time by the
same person and I'm like I can't cut
myself in four pieces and all that
Echoes what Kim told E.T back in 2019. I
want to make sure each kid gets so much
of my attention I think four is the
perfect magic number for me but despite
the challenges that come with being a
mom Kim says it's the most rewarding job
of all there's nothing that can prepare
you I don't care how long you wait I
don't care what you're waiting for you
are never prepared but you will figure
it out and it will make you so proud of
yourself